when you see that happening to your
beloved City what goes through your mind
and do you think something's going wrong
there here he is you may remember this
one uh this about two months ago
explaining why uh there are no
businesses left in San Francisco you see
what's happening there we do see
businesses moving out for various
reasons but some of them saying they're
concerned about the crime in the area
when you see that happening to your
beloved City what goes through your mind
and do you think something's going wrong
there they're struggling to recover from
the pandemic they're struggling to come
back they're struggling with the the the
macroeconomic shifts particularly as it
relates to uh Tork as it relates to
what's the future of a downtown is it
stacking of offices or stacking of
people and they're in the process of
rezoning and rebirth and reimagination
by the way I've seen that in San
Francisco for decades yeah it's just
words it's just words and I get it dude
your suit fits well the slime in your
hair is good I get it the work on your
teeth you've done it all right right and
and I get that they'll probably figure
out a way to get old bones out of the
way and make you the nominee and all of
that stuff but it's all just meaningless
right oh it's postco whatever why aren't
we having that here why is it that
everywhere you go in Florida and I look
I'm in Miami which is obviously one of
the most thriving cities in the entire
world or certainly the most thriving in
America right now but you can go
virtually anywhere in Florida and there
are stores opening everywhere there are
people moving everywhere roads being
built everywhere do we not have the same
macroeconomic Trends do we not have the
same uh
postco hangover well actually we don't
because Florida treated covid a bit
differently